electric light spring medieval wolf to
life this was town of Merton is glowing
in the winter dark
[Music]
and festival-goers eyes seemed to light
up along with it
see ya it's very good i'm impressed guys
it's very nice the interpreter
technology with the old buildings and
it's very nice she's dying there's girls
hot it's really something special it's
got so many objects and so many people
are coming and you keep running into
something new it's just full of great
ideas always awful bosal mammoth the
light festival's main attraction is an
animation projected onto the local
school building by the French artist
group spectaculaire
[Music]
it's a lesson in imagination not just
for kids said release well it's a story
that everyone knows everyone's been to
school it's got just enough poetry and
nostalgia to send every one big and
small back to school little monthly
proceeding home Erica Morton and the
canton of free ball has just over eight
thousand residents and is located on the
german french language border the old
town with his ring wall and nearby leg
moga a tourist attractions in the summer
the festival of lights was conceived to
give people a reason to visit in winter
as well the emotion it isn't event I
know we'd like this event with the light
animations to generate a little bit of a
buzz in the winter our aim is very clear
over the next five to ten years we want
to become Switzerland's capital of light
Philistine yahan some 40 regional and
international artists are taking part
Gloria they is from Germany she's been
working with light graphics and
installations for about 10 years now
when she heard about the festival of
lights and morden she came here to let
the town inspire her yeah I'm Hinduism
Wharton's e on dev our clothes liqui
inspired me to see what happens when I
look into the water what are whom do i
see my reflection means they see no mage
bigger boot or do I look into my soul do
I see other people and women or sunken
tails in the water navassa she created a
projection for the Chateau courtyard I
showed that changes a little bit every
evening because Claudia a alters it live
a few hundred meters away in the church
light is combined with music the
musicians carefully time they're playing
to coincide with the action of the light
animation
[Music]
modern is hosting a total of thirty-six
installations the organizers expect up
to a hundred thousand visitors some of
the attractions are even interactive
[Music]
yeah thoughtless he needs pretty even I
found it very inspiring really
interesting exciting some things were
also very funny it was fun the festival
of lights goes for 12 days 12 days for
Merton to prove its Switzerland capital
of light